bonsoir jean jacques kourliandsky merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
a dans l'annulation de l'ensemble des
condamnations dont faisait l'objet lula
par la cour surprême cour suprême
brésilienne c'était pour le moins
inattendu oui c'est inattendu mais une
première remarque c'est une décision qui
annule la forme mais pas le fond
personne ne sait exactement ce qui va se
passer l'année prochaine si le procès du
président lula va se réouvrir avant
l'élection ou après l'élection compte
tenu du fonctionnement de la justice
brésilienne et qui était une très lié au
rythme de la vie politique
ces dernières années on assiste à une
judiciarisation de la de la vie
politique
rien ne peut être exclu soit le
président l'ex président lula peut
effectivement si le procès ne reprend
pas si la procédure se prolonge se
présentait effectivement à l'élection
soit le jugement un jugement se produit
avant l'élection et personne ne peut
préjuger du résultat de cette procédure
parce que c'est important de dire vous
l'avez dit que que lula n'est pas
innocenté il devrait être jugé donc par
un tribunal fédéral de brasilia c'est
bien cela qui reviendra sur les
accusations qui portent contre lui tout
à fait alors tout dépend du calendrier
si le calendrier se prolonge si la
procédure se prolonge
effectivement il sera en condition de se
présenter si la procédure accélérée sous
la pression du procureur général qui a
été nommé par le président ball sont
aaron notamment alors on ne peut pas
préjuger du résultat et on ne peut pas
exclure ce qui le scénario qui s'est
produit en 2018 ou le président l'ex
président lula était candidat
ils étaient favoris porté par les
sondages et quelques mois avant les
élections la justice l'a fait
incarcéré il n'a pas pu se présenter et
le pt a été obligé de fabriquer au
dernier moment un candidat et une
campagne électorale qui s'est déroulé
dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles alors la gauche brésilienne a
évidemment salué la nouvelle les
soutiens de jaillir balle sonar ou e.on
et accusé le juge d'avoir pris une
décision politique
c'est crédible justement vous parlez de
la judiciarisation de la vie politique
c'est crédible cette accusation de
décisions politiques c'est vrai que
comment ne pas être politique quand on
prend ce genre de décision effectivement
mais oui mais on peut s'étonner de la
décision du tribunal suprême fait
supérieur fédéral
le procès lavage à tout a commencé en
mai 2016 avec la première perquisition
des domiciles du président lula sur
décision de la justice de curitiba et
notamment d'un juge qui a fait beaucoup
parler de lui et qui a été désigné comme
ministre de la justice par le vainqueur
des élections de 2010 8 jaillir volson
haro donc on peut s'étonner que le
tribunal supérieur fédéral s'aperçoivent
donc cinq ans après que le tribunal de
curitiba n'était pas le tribunal adéquat
pour juger un ex président de la
république donc l'accusation qui est
porté aujourd'hui par veille wolson haro
sur la politisation de la justice peut
lui être renvoyée parce que jusqu'à
présent c'était plutôt le président lula
qui avait souffert de ce fonctionnement
entre guillemets politique de la justice
l or est ce qu'on peut déjà le
considérer comme le principal concurrent
adversaires politiques de jaillir bol
sonar aussi toutefois il pourra une
place se présenter en 2000
2 quelle serait alors selon vous ses
chances de l'emporter alors la situation
aujourd'hui n'est pas celle des
élections de 2002 et celle de 2007 qui
avait été gagné par le président lula ni
même 2010 qui a été gagné par qui avait
été gagné par la candidate du pt
dilma rousseff le pt a beaucoup souffert
de ces dernières années notamment en
novembre l'année dernière aux élections
municipales et l'a perdu un quart des
municipalités qu'il détenait le jeu
politique s'est réorganisé y compris à
gauche
et si le président lula est candidat il
n'est pas certain qu'ils soient le seul
candidat de gauche le candidat de centre
gauche qui s'étaient présentés en 2018
parallèlement quand il a dû péter il
s'appelle siro gomes comme il a du pdt
d'ailleurs fait un commentaire sur la
situation actuelle et de l'ex président
lula en déclarant qu'il était très
satisfait très content que le président
l'ex président lula soit rétabli dans
ses droits citoyens dans ses droits
civiques mais que la situation n'était
pas la même et que donc que ce qui
laisse entendre qu'il reste candidat
quelle que soit la situation du
président lula quelle que soit la
décision que prendra le président lula
aux élections de 2022
alors ce qui est certain ce qui est vrai
c'est que le président lula a un
charisme personnel
il a et il va bien au delà du qui va
bien au delà du pt il a la capacité de
commandes et d'éviter qu'il y ait
certaines candidat de gauche
candidatures de gauche je pense
notamment à une candidature du parti
communiste du brésil de pc doumbé et une
candidature du pétrole qui sont deux
partis situés 10 ans à la gauche du
du pt mais il est possible qu'il y ait
d'autres candidats de gauche et en
particulier le la candidature du
personnage que je viens d'évoquer siro
gomes qui avait fait 11 % des suffrages
au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2018
alors il faut préciser qu'à la suite de
cette annonce de l'annulation des
charges contre lui le cours de la bourse
a chuté au brésil est ce que sa
politique de gauche inquiète clairement
les les marchés financiers les marchés
financiers sont surtout inquiet de 1,1
élément d'incertitude supplémentaire de
leur point de vue mais ils sont tout
aussi inquiet de la façon dont le
président bolt son art au gère le pays
gère le brésil d'abord la crise
sanitaire qui est gérée de façon
catastrophique il ya eu encore hier plus
de 1100 décès au brésil avec une
incohérence totale dans la politique de
gestion des gestes barrières qui n'est
qu'il n'est pratiquement 1 existed
existantes au niveau du gouvernement
fédéral incohérences au niveau de la
gestion des vaccinations est également
et des incohérences en matière
économique
le président molson araud a bradé un
certain nombre d'actifs importants
économique du brésil il a tenu des
propos assez agressif à l'égard de la
chine et qui est le premier acheteur le
premier client des produits agricoles et
minéraux brésilien ce cas incommodé les
groupes agro exportateurs brésiliens qui
a incommodé également la justice ce qui
a eu des démêlés avec le président bolle
son art ou a eu des démêlés avec les
juges ces derniers temps et à tel point
que tous ces milieux financiers de
grande presse est à la recherche
aujourd'hui d'un candidat alternatif qui
serait plus rationnel plus présentable
on a beaucoup parlé ces derniers temps
du gouverneur de l'état de sao paulo
monsieur doriot qui effectivement s'est
engagée de façon
très franche très active a pris beaucoup
d'initiatives en vue de trouver des
solutions à la crise sanitaire au moins
à haut niveau de son de son état celui
de sang parle donc la libération disons
la restitution plus tôt dès aujourd'hui
des droits civiques du président lula
doit aussi beaucoup à ce climat
critiques de la part des de
l'établissement brésilien
l'établissement judiciaire
l'établissement politique de droite de
l'établissement certains milieux
économiques et donc la situation
effectivement est ouverte
beaucoup plus ouverte qu'elle ne l'était
avant cette décision du tribunal
supérieur fédéral
mais on ne se trouve pas dans le
scénario de 2003 2002 pardon et 2007 et
même 2010 dans lesquelles le pt le
candidat du pt était assuré à coup sûr
de gagner l'élection présidentielle
merci jean jacques kourliandsky
chercheur à l'iris spécialiste de
l'espagne d'amérique latine d'avoir été
avec nous